i am not fun on a vacation no you have
to have your routine
never invite me on a vacation i don't
like groups of people
getting together at all i mean ask bobba
bowie how fun i am at a dinner party
he had a lovely party at his house and i
ruined it okay i got a question we
talked about this on wrap-up yesterday
robin
yeah if somebody invited you to a dinner
and they said it's a dinner there's
going to be a cocktail hour then we're
going to have a full course dinner
and it started at seven what time would
you expect it to be over by
7 30. howard was at 8 40. i'm not saying
you did anything wrong
it's me i mean cocktail hour went to at
least eight o'clock
maybe later it went that's an hour
cocktail hour
and that's an hour where i am just
[ __ ] miserable
got to sit there and talk to all of
gary's guests
our guests were us exactly right
i saw you all day i'm going to [ __ ]
see you at the youtuber i invited
strangers
like you're more interested to say to
these people
i mean i saw gary's house it was lovely
i was ready for dinner and then there
was this whole slow
built-up dinner yeah they had a chef i'm
not interested
dinner okay it was multiple courses it
was slow but at like eight
too slow 8 42 you were like screaming
for dessert
i know i couldn't take it
i couldn't take it you're like bad
i just you know what i wanted to do i
wanted to pull up to gary's house and
have dinner handed to me in a bag
to be a drive-through can i just say one
more thing that's interesting about that
night
so we say everybody be there at six
right now howard
is notoriously punctual okay all right
but it was like it was like 5 40 and we
were like getting everything together
and mary looks out the window she goes i
think howard's car is like parked across
the street
yeah i wanted to get you going early i
know well i would have come in but beth
goes that's rude you're supposed to wait
yeah you're not supposed to show up
early oh and then i get in the car and i
go oh thank god we're out of there and
beth will be like you know
it was such a lovely night you know i
think it would have been nice to have
the dessert with everyone else and
yeah oh that's not true i go that's not
true you know stop making me feel bad
i said let's go back we'll eat the
[ __ ] dessert the car with
a bag of dessert
oh if i could have i would have gotten
in and out before anyone saw me
i would have been done with the party
party i hate the word party
what's wrong with that word i don't need
a party i'm having a party
i'm having my own party where are you in
my house in my house and his head
i watched feud
[Music]
if you had had feud on gary it would
have been perfect
i will give you credit for one thing
though like even when if if howard has
you at his own house
right yeah he's the one throwing the
party he will leave the party
and tell him he'll leave you at his
party someone once said to me they
didn't know me very well and they went
i went to a guy's house and the guy left
his own party and i went and that's
weird
let's face it i'm that guy i'm no fun so
if somebody's thinking of going away on
vacation with me
jimmy hasn't given up on me though he
wants to go away with me more well you
like having him to your house
right that's fine i don't want to go
anywhere else
but if he wants to come to my house i'm
fine with that i enjoy you know and
jimmy's kind of like you know off the
air when he's not on tv he's like a
potted plant
he just kind of like he sits there he
knows how to hang he knows how to hang
with me
which is not to hang with me